people learn more from a diverse set of
experiences than they do from common
experiences I'm from Denmark Mexico in
South Africa London from Romania remind
California bangalore it's truly a
diverse group we have people from so
many different industries and countries
Virgil chili Hong Kong Houston Texas
leisure and from Israel Brazil Singapore
whether it's from a different country a
different industry folks learn from each
other with the faculty being catalyst
for that line people are very dedicated
for achieving something and from Spain
Northern Nevada Sydney Japan China so
many of my peers whether they're in a
different continent a different country
are still dealing with exactly the same
issues that I'm doing with as a leader
coming out of this definitely a lot more
skilled doing business outside your home
turf you now have true industry experts
that you can actually call upon without
any hesitation be prepared to system
apart from the learning the biggest
takeaways the network fabulous
friendships absolutely different
backgrounds you really are able to build
a great network of people around the
world there's so many great people yes
it's so accomplished and it's just a
privilege and an honor to beat them to
network with them to pick their brains
and be able to learn a lot
you